hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president biden signing a flurry of
executive orders
a number in an effort to curb the spread
of the coronavirus
and deliver economic assistance to
americans in need
others aim to roll back president
trump's actions on the environment and
immigration
fox news correspondent jillian turner
breaks down these measures
the biden team's immigration reform bill
and discusses if there was an appetite
in congress to pass it
president biden once again urging the
nation to come together in his inaugural
address
fox news sunday host chris wallace
weighs in on the commander-in-chief's
agenda for his first 100 days in office
and whether his calls for unity will
have an impact
plus commentary from former white house
speechwriter and fox news contributor
mark thiessen
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm greg jarrett i'm shannon bream i'm
steve ducey and this
is the fox news rundown
friday january 22nd 2021
i'm lisa brady an early focus on
immigration
for president biden but is congress
ready to try again
republicans today are saying there's
less appetite for immigration reform
writ
large in congress today than there was
back in 2013
when there was another dramatic
legislative overhaul
democrats are saying they now have the
majority so they can move
full steam ahead i'm chris foster it's a
new almost certainly
quieter era of american politics there's
no question biden is going to be
a more and i say this in a in a certain
way
boring president he's not going to be in
your face every day i think that's one
of the things people voted for
you speak with fox news sunday host
chris wallace and i'm mark thiessen i've
got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
the pandemic is priority one for the new
president we'll move
heaven and earth to get more people
vaccinated
for free and create more places for them
to get vaccinated
on thursday signing executive orders
designed to speed more covert related
supplies
including vaccines and more testing and
to help schools and businesses reopen
but president biden has also been moving
quickly to reverse
some of president trump's decisions and
much of that
is focused on immigration the acting
homeland security
secretary issued a memorandum to review
and reset immigration enforcement
priorities
white house press secretary jen sakhi
announcing a pause on deportations
while a mixture of executive actions and
proposed legislation
targets everything from the border wall
and the travel ban
to asylum policies the plan would also
allow an eight-year path to citizenship
for undocumented immigrants already here
and a shorter path for the so-called
dreamers
brought here illegally as children i was
disappointed
to see within hours of assuming office
the new administration
was more interested in helping illegal
immigrants than helping our own citizens
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
argues now is not the time for more
lenient immigration rules when millions
of americans are out of work
from the pandemic but are these mainly
symbolic moves so far or will they have
an impact
i would wager that all of them are going
to have a real and immediate impact
on the people who they target fox news
correspondent jillian turner
some of the executive orders he passed
did things
like he's now stopped construction of
the southern border wall that has a
direct impact on people's lives on
major contracts that the u.s federal
government
has he's reversed the so-called muslim
travel ban which means that people from
those countries can again travel to the
united states that has a direct
impact on those people's lives and then
now he's also making moves
to protect the children of undocumented
immigrants
the so-called dreamers that are covered
under daca so i'd say all of these
things really
directly impact people's lives the white
house
themselves are billing all of these
changes
as a quote return to normalcy and a
quote to decency and they're centering
these things from a pr perspective
around american families they're saying
this is about
healing and providing normalcy for
american families that have been
separated from one another because of
these policies
do we know though how effective some of
these policies that are now reversed
had been in addressing the immigration
problem the answer to that question
depends on
who you ask so if you ask republican
lawmakers on capitol hill
if you ask republicans who first
supported president trump they'll tell
you all these policies he enacted were
incredibly effective they'll tell you
the muslim ban travel policy kept people
out of the united states who came from
countries who weren't complying
with guidelines set by the u.s federal
government
about information sharing they weren't
sharing information about suspected
terrorists
and other people whose records had
things on them the united states was
interested in pursuing
they will tell you that building the
border wall created
sovereignty for the united states that
has been lacking sorely for decades and
was keeping illegal immigrants
from south america out of the country
now if you ask democrats they'll tell
you
that none of those objectives were even
worth achieving in the first place
anyway because they
don't represent american values america
doesn't want to keep people from foreign
countries outside of its borders we want
to bring them in
and embrace them and help them create
better lives
and they'll tell you that they also want
to bring those people in because they
contribute to the economy
so where you where you stand on this
issue
really depends on which side of the
aisle you sit on
where does the asylum policy stand now
because asylum seekers had been waiting
in mexico
instead of waiting inside the u.s for
cases to be heard under one of the new
uh trump administration policies is is
that changing too
well jen saki said in her press
conference
that the biden administration wanted to
restart welcoming refugees and asylum
seekers back into the united states so
presumably those people are going to get
moving really quickly he signed these
executive orders now
but obviously it's not the kind of
policy that you can really
enact overnight you can sign all the
paperwork you want but you have to have
people at the border
to process people who are coming into
the united states you've got to have
people there to do
background checks you've got to have
people you've got to have the budget in
place so that when you bring refugees
into the country
you can support them with government
services a lot of that was cut back
during the trump administration it will
take some time to rebuild
up to the point where we were at the end
of the obama administration
right able to accept more people
arriving at the border i guess but the
incoming administration had already
started sending signals
to new caravans of immigrants that
formed south of the border before the
inauguration
um you know not to come right now at
least not yet
they're on their way anyway though have
we been given any indication how
they plan to handle that well the
caravans
are sort of continuous motion machines
there's always one caravan or another
headed towards the united states at any
given point in time
so the bonding administration you're
right did make signals that they wanted
the latest coming i believe from
guatemala not to come right away
who knows if they're going to listen or
not they're also
i know putting a pause on deportations
what is what does that mean practically
speaking
does that mean not removing criminals as
well is it a full pause
it does according to the experts and
sources that we've been talking to
today they're putting a pause on
certain non-citizens so that means
people who are here without documents
or who are here illegally it's our
understanding that this is going to
impact thousands of people currently in
the country
so those people are now going to be here
indefinitely
and they haven't said what's going to
happen
after the pause is over in terms of
whether they resume
a certain amount of deportations or do
we know where it goes from there
no they have not specified anything any
of those details yet
president biden certainly favors a path
to citizenship
something that critics historically have
called amnesty and it's something that's
been
really a partisan wedge every time it's
come up in
immigration related legislation in the
past
is there any indication that at this
point in time
immigration reform has a better chance
on on capitol hill other than the fact
that democrats now have the majority in
both chambers
and the white house republicans today
are saying there's
less appetite for immigration reform
writ large in congress today than there
was back in 2013
when there was another dramatic
legislative overhaul
democrats are saying they now have the
majority so they can move full
steam ahead on this issue this always
becomes
as soon as this issue of some kind of a
large-scale
overhaul is raised it immediately
becomes
the big ticket item what it includes
specifically is a pathway to citizenship
for 11 million undocumented immigrants
who are currently here
and under the new proposed body
legislation
each of those people would now
be on a path where they can attain
full-fledged citizenship with all the
attendant rights
in eight years so it's something that
congress is going to have to debate
really thoroughly over the coming days
it seems unlikely that a whole lot of
republicans are going to get on board
i know republicans usually push for
enhanced security measures as part of
negotiations on an immigration bill
that's what they've done in the past
though in the trump years enhanced
security
was usually you know kind of language
that was used when they were really
talking about the border wall
so now that uh by executive order the
new president has said
we're stopping that or at least stopping
the diversion of funds
that was helping it to continue um
could there maybe be some bipartisan
agreement on other security measures
like
you know better use of technology
instead of the wall at the border
it could be or it could be that stopping
the
construction of the border wall
completely is only going to inflame
republicans and create more division and
because of that they're going to hold
out on the biden administration
and refuse to give an inch on
immigration
at all i could see it going really
either way here
fox's jillian turner thank you so much
for your time you bet thanks so much
[Music]
this is mark thiessen with your fox news
commentary coming up
we're a couple days into the new biden
administration with executive orders
already signed on the coronavirus
response climate change immigration
diversity and more
he's asking congress to support his plan
for more common virus financial relief
and whatever happens politically he says
let's start fresh let's begin to listen
to one another again
hear one another see one another
show respect to one another politics
doesn't have to be a raging fire
destroying everything in its path
every disagreement doesn't have to be a
cause for total war
that's president biden during his
inaugural address well i thought he did
made a very effective speech i thought
it was it was just right
chris wallace is the host of fox news
sunday in two aspects one
you know it it obviously comes against
the backdrop of the fact that exactly 14
days before there were insurrectionists
running wild on that platform
uh trying to crash the capital and keep
our dually elected officials from
from performing their constitutional
duties and two i i really liked the tone
of it it wasn't
one of those uh inaugural addresses for
the ages
it was a it to me it was joe biden
talking over the backyard
fence to his neighbors saying we've got
to stop this politics as a bloodsport
is is killing the country and we've got
to find a way
to debate you know we're going to
disagree but to debate issues
responsibly ascribing good faith to each
other and
try to move the country forward i
thought it was just what we needed
yeah i mean he talked about unity in
that speech a little differently
than he had during the campaign when he
was sort of pushing this notion and
we'll go back to the days when
you know guys go and work it out over a
steak in a cocktail
now he's using terms like getting enough
people on board
he knows he's not ever going to be all
things to all people that this wasn't
like
the obama speech where it felt like okay
i'm elected now everything's better
um no no and that i think it's look he's
a if nothing if not
a realist but you know he was saying i'm
going to be the president to all the
people and hear me out
uh and and you know debate
within the guard rails of democracy is
fine but this union isn't and you know
and
again oh it was very much colored by
the fact that just 14 days before there
were thousands
thousands of peoples forming the capital
looking to
take nancy pelosi and mike pence captive
i mean that's a pretty
you know it's an unprecedented thing and
i think he needed to speak about it
yeah and that riot was precipitated by a
series
of lies about election fraud and
the president talked a little bit about
that during his speech saying look
that needs to stop yeah i agree and and
you know i think it was a call to all of
us he talked at one point he said
there's truth and there are lies
and there are lies that are uh spread
for power and profit
and i think that's a cautionary message
to us in the media
to people on social media to people in
their twitter accounts
you know you can have any opinion you
want but let's not be spreading lies
about elections being stolen or
uh uh count election you know vote count
machines that were
uh you know set by venezuela
and uh and the russians i mean it's just
it
you know we that was so destructive
these these last two months have been so
terrible for the country and we
we just need to get back to reality
president obama
is perceived by at least a lot of
democrats maybe resentful democrats that
having squandered some of his early time
in office
joe biden seems to be taking some pretty
big swings on his own to the extent that
he can without congress do you see any
pitfalls for him any mistakes to avoid
or do you like what he's doing so far um
well it's not a matter of like or not
it's it's a matter of
elections have consequences and you know
some people and i think this is silly
are saying well you know he talks about
unity and then he then he signed 17
executive orders well of course he is he
won
you know he these are things he promised
in his campaign and i don't see that as
disunion
i mean nobody is saying that that you
calls for unity mean we're all going to
get together and
democrats aren't going to pursue their
agenda uh
you know that's ridiculous just as when
donald trump came in i don't think
people were
uh shocked that he was actually going to
do things that he said he was going to
do that
that's that's that's legitimate that's
why we hold elections
uh but but you know there's a difference
between people pursuing
an agenda within the guardrails of
democracy as biden put it
and and and you know basically trying to
burn down
in this case the capital and that's and
that that's just
there's a line there and i don't
understand why people have uh
trouble distinguishing one from the
other there are some democrats
maybe on the left who want really not
much to do with unity
anyway they say that ship has sailed
it's time for boots on necks and taking
every single inch that we can
well the fact is joe biden beat those
folks
uh you know there was bernie sanders ran
and there was
uh and and was supported by uh aoc
and uh elizabeth warren ran and biden
ran
he's a liberal he's certainly left of
center but he ran as a much more
moderate much more centrist
liberal democrat and he beat him and you
know i think it's been clear
from the people he's put in his cabinet
and the policies he's pursuing
uh you know he's not he he campaigned
against
uh medicare for all he campaigned
against
the green new deal yes he wants to see
health care reform and yes he wants to
see
climate change legislation but he isn't
for those extreme
uh positions and that first of all
they're not going to happen you got a 50
50 senate you got
a a a margin of about four or five votes
for the democrats in the house
you know that's went out the window with
the very narrow results in the election
uh but in addition it isn't what he
believes in
the democrats do technically control the
senate now
uh how does chuck schumer operate
differently now as majority leader
how does mitch mcconnell operate
differently now as minority leader he's
been in that position before chuck
schumer has not
right well uh you know he controls
what gets on the floor there's nothing
more important than that what
what gets up for just a debate and a
vote in the on the senate floor
and what doesn't uh you know that was
the tremendous power
that uh mcconnell had to set the agenda
for the senate uh and now it will be
chuck schumer's
but having said that uh and
particularly these last two years
mcconnell didn't have what was it 53
47 he didn't have much of a majority and
now schumer has a what a one vote it's
going to be
you know assuming that it's party line
on some issues uh
there's going to be one vote kamala
harris the the
presiding officer the vice president to
break a type what i hope
and maybe this is just you know foolish
idealism on my part
is that it isn't party line votes you
know there are there is
a small centrist lobby uh
in in the senate you know and you can
include people uh
sort of more conservative democrats like
joe manchin and john tester and kirsten
cinema
and more moderate republicans
like mitt romney and susan collins and
lisa murkowski
and boy how great would it be if you
could get this bipartisan group in the
center
that kind of steered us and that we were
able to get things
accomplished you know it's going to be
awfully hard to get 60 votes to get 10
republicans on top of the 50 democrats
so that you can break a filibuster but
it seems to me on a lot of important
legislation or certainly
on on financial stuff that you can do
through reconciliation
that you know you could get uh you know
53 54 votes for
stuff if it's moderate enough if it's
centrist enough
and and that's what the founders wanted
that's why they created the senate the
way they did
so that you know it's you got to get
some bipartisan buy-in you can't just
ram it through on a straight party line
vote
we're getting back to what used to be
standard for at least a few years there
these daily press babies in the white
house
somebody asked a question the president
spokesperson answered it maybe there's
some obfuscation but
probably not an outright right lie and
everybody just goes on with their day
but when those went away under president
trump it was kind of weird at first but
then everybody got by
do you think they're still useful with
the communication methods we have now
are you happy to see jen saki up there
every day absolutely
yes uh you know look let's not fool
ourselves and let's
you know she works for the president she
said well he works for the american
people and i work for him so i work for
the american people
yes but she she works for the president
she's the president spokesperson she's
going to put the president's spin on
issues
but uh you know she's she's a good
serious responsible person there are you
know i i was in the white house
press room for six years covering ronald
reagan and dealing with the
the press secretary there's a lot of
useful information that comes out of
those
if it's an administration that wants to
put useful information out i thought by
the end with kaylee mcananey
they became absolutely useless because
it really was a campaign
platform and had nothing to do with
trying to inform the american people
what its government is doing now i it
went both ways i thought it became
far too aggressive uh and
confrontational on the part of the white
house press secretaries i thought it
became far too confrontational
on the part of the white house press
corps but you know if we could go back
to
businesses usual briefings where
reporters ask
serious questions and get serious
answers
uh and and look it's not going to be as
as nice as it was
yesterday every administration gets into
trouble they get into controversies
people
screw up white house press corps is
going to jump on that like
sharks with blood in the water and
that's all part of the process too
but if if it if it remains
basically civil uh and information and
fact-based
i think it's a very useful thing well
chris uh
two weeks ago we were talking about a
ride at the capitol last week we were
talking about impeachment now we've got
a new president um
i'm relieved that maybe we're gonna have
a little bit less to talk about
next week well
you know look one of the things about
the news business is why you got into it
it's why i got into it is truth is
always stranger than fiction
you know you can't imagine what we've
been through you could never write it
what we were through the last four years
i i there's no question biden is going
to be a more
and i say this in a in a certain way
boring president he's not going to be in
your face every day i think
that's one of the things people voted
for but you know there are a lot of big
issues
uh we got covid we've got terrible
economic problems
you've got this you know the future of
the republican party
uh you know it's going to be trump
republicans or traditional republicans
there's going to be plenty to talk about
all right good we'll do it chris wallace
host of fox news sunday thanks man you
bet thank you chris
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
this week the world met amanda gorman
in the space of five minutes using 723
words
amanda's poem the hill we climb became
one of the most talked about
aspects of the inauguration of president
joe biden mr president
dr biden madam vice
president mr imhof
americans and the world and at 22
she's become the youngest inaugural poet
ever in the u.s
when day comes we ask ourselves where
can we find
light in this never-ending shade
the loss we carry a sea we must wade
we've
braved the belly of the gorman who
studied sociology at harvard
at times brought her personal story to
the forefront finished we
the successors of the country and a time
where a skinny black girl descended from
slaves
and raised by a single mother can dream
of becoming president only to find
herself
reciting for one there was more than one
nod to the musical hamilton
including references to the song history
has its eyes on you sung by george
washington in the play
scripture tells us to envision that
everyone shall sit under their own vine
and fig tree and no one shall make them
afraid if we're to live up to her own
time
then victory won't lie she says she
listened to the broadway cast recording
while working on the piece
which she finished writing in the hours
following the january 6th riot at the
u.s capitol the very place
she stood to recite her words on
wednesday
we've seen a force that would shatter
our nation
rather than share it would destroy our
country if it meant delaying
democracy and this effort very nearly
succeeded but while democracy can be
periodically delayed it can never
be permanently defeated in 2017 amanda
became the first national youth poet
laureate at just 19 years old
an age at which she declared she would
run for president in 2036.
the inaugural introduction may have been
the first major event for her this year
but it's not the last
in september her debut poetry collection
will be released
as well as a picture book for young
readers more steps
toward the bright future that lies ahead
for amanda gorman
south we will rebuild reconcile and
recover and every known nook
of our nation in every corner called our
country
our people diverse and beautiful will
emerge
battered and beautiful when day comes we
step
out of the shade a flame and unafraid
the new dawn blooms
as we free it for there is always light
if only we're brave enough to see it if
only
we're brave enough to be it tanya j
powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
mark
what's on your mind in his inaugural
address president biden extended an
olive branch to supporters of former
president donald trump
let's start afresh all of us he said
let's begin to listen to one another
again
hear one another see one another show
respect to one another
politics doesn't have to be a raging
fire destroying everything in its path
unquote he asked trump supporters quote
to hear me out as we move forward
to take a measure of me in my heart if
you still disagree so be it that's
democracy
he said but he added the time had come
to quote end this uncivil war that pits
red against blue
rural versus urban conservative versus
liberal
and he promised that quote my whole soul
is in this bringing america together
uniting our people uniting our nation
unquote
for a nation wounded by rancor division
and insurrection
those words were a bomb but as biden
also noted in his address
delivering on those promises quote
requires so much more than words
end quote what he does in his first days
in office will determine whether his
words will have real meaning
if biden really wants to restore unity
there are three specific steps he could
take
first he needs to find a major
initiative to work with on republicans
early in his presidency
when president bill clinton took office
one of the first things he did was push
for passage of the north american free
trade agreement
negotiated by his republican predecessor
and opposed by many in his own party
when president george w bush took office
one of the first things he did was reach
out to the most liberal member of the
united states senate
ted kennedy and offer to work with him
to pass what became the no child left
behind act
biden needs his own equivalent of no
child left behind a major initiative
that can bring conservatives and
liberals together
and help legislators on both sides of
the aisle begin flexing their bipartisan
muscles again
second unity requires compromise and the
mechanism that ensures compromise and
bipartisanship is the filibuster which
allows the senate minority to delay or
block legislation
biden is the first president since
lyndon johnson who is truly a man of the
senate
so he understands you can't restore
unity while trampling the rights of the
minority at the same time
if he wants to restore unity he and
fellow democrats will have to moderate
their demands
agree to some republican priorities and
sometimes accept no for an answer
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
is pressing majority leader chuck
schumer
to preserve the legislative filibuster
as part of their agreement governing the
rules of the 50-50 senate
biden should tell schumer he supports
such an agreement
finally biden can't restore unity if the
democratic senate spends the next six to
eight weeks
presiding over the impeachment trial of
his predecessor
trump's incitement of the january 6
capital riots was an impeachable offense
where he's still in office his removal
might be warranted but trump has left
the white house
does biden really want washington
focused on his predecessor's failings
instead of his own priorities
during the first critical weeks of his
presidency a trial would be divisive and
distracting
biden should urge schumer and house
speaker nancy pelosi to put aside the
articles of
impeachment so congress could start
working to enact his agenda
in his address biden said quote this is
our historic moment of crisis and
challenge and unity
is the path forward unquote by taking
these steps
he can rise to the moment and give that
promise meeting i'm mark thiessen
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast
at foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa
just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it
on demand from fox news and amazon alexa
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes